l'ancienne salle de consultation des
fiches pour chaque période historique
elle lundi à sedin passera son épreuve
d'histoire
le baccalauréat un examen qui stresse le
jeune homme de 20 ans c'est un diplôme
qui va me permettre de m'ouvrir des
portes pour mon futur j'aimerais jusqu'à
un bac + 5 en gestion de concessions
automobiles comme tu as aidé mais sont
une trentaine de candidats à être venu
chercher un soutien dans leurs révisions
à la médiathèque du canal ils reçoivent
un coaching personnalisé dans ses
derniers instants et sont beaucoup
demandeur de la méthodologie et de la
gestion du temps en fait comment gérer
leur temps sur les quatre heures
d'épreuve et aussi quel choix
stratégiques mettre en place quand on
est bloqué leur donner des outils pour
arriver à mémoriser toutes les
connaissances qu'on leur demande
d'acquérir sur la période du bac tout ce
qui est gestion éventuelle des émotions
du stress de l'anxiété de la surprise
face à un sujet qui nous déstabilise
savoir apprendre de savoir travailler en
fait y'a pas que les connaissances et le
coaching scolaire permis entre autres
permet les permis sa 17 juin top départ
de six jours d'épreuves les résultats
sont attendus le 5 juillet prochain
en 2010 8 86% des candidats de
l'académie de versailles ont obtenu le
précieux sésame